i am patricia oliver and this is my
husband manuel
two years ago our beautiful son joaquin
was shot and killed at parkland
every day i think about him and what his
last moments
must have been like meanwhile
every day nearly 100 more families lose
someone they love to gun violence
every single day we keep telling people
it doesn't have to be like this
they don't listen so we found a way to
bring back someone
that no one will ignore it's very hard
for me to look at this
so please please listen to what our son
has to say
[Music]
yo it's me it's guac
i've been gone for two years and
nothing's changed bro
people are still getting killed by guns
what is that everyone knows it but they
don't do anything
i'm tired of waiting for someone to fix
it
the election in november is the first
one i could have voted in
but i'll never get to choose the kind of
world i wanted to live in
so you've got to replace my vote
go to unfinishedvotes.com register
then go vote vote for politicians who
care more about people's lives
than the gun lobby's money vote for
people not getting shot bro
i mean vote for me because i can't
we've got to keep on fighting and we got
to end this
well that was fun i like that
i think that's fun i think that's a good
idea i think reanimating the corpses of
people to come back and make political
points is a good idea and i know many of
you
probably are watching this program
didn't expect me to come down on that
side of the issue but i like it
i like it i like making technology work
for us
i think it is such a cool way to get a
message across
just bring people back from the dead and
put words
in their mouth and maybe did he say his
name was guac
his name is joaquin oliver okay but he
goes by guac he goes by guac
yeah in the beginning he said hey it's
guac
if i die please reanimate me and
have me just slinging promo codes i hope
ridge wallet does it
i hope if i die ridge wallet brings me
back from the dead
and i'm just like i used to sling these
wallets for years on my show
and i've been dead for three years and
they're still great quality
and they're still great value
i would have bought these wallets if i
was alive but i'm not i'm
dead i don't know
it's a little disturbing but i get it
they're passionate
and they feel like what can we do
i would have liked if they did a rap
song if they had made joaquin oliver
or rapper he could have came back
and did a rap song you know
that would have been a little more
impressive i get it
you could do the uh you could recreate
the voice in the imagery
creepy but i know it's possible but
make a hit you really want the kids
involved
make a hit that's what i'm saying
have them do a talk
bring him back i want him back again for
a tick-tock
viral dance challenge
and a hit song i respect that he's got a
political message
but let's take it one step further this
is
the beginning of the dystopia that we
discuss
on this show day in and day out
uh forever since we've begun talking
uh this is it's materializing now i
don't know
if now that it's materializing i'm gonna
have to go in like a whole
other direction right because it's
almost it's like
barely funny now that it's here you know
what i mean
like it's like it's kind of at a point
now where it's like
substantially less funny that it's
arrived
and it's just mouth of gape jaw dropping
holy [ __ ] they are literally bringing
back a dead kid
to do a [ __ ] psa about voting
like this is literally happening it's
real
his parents are doing that this is
nuts the president of the united states
has covered
the doomsday planes are in the air maybe
i was wrong maybe jimmy fallon and the
muppets
are the way to go maybe i was wrong
how i mean
it's it's truly
i said the other night on stage where
nashville here that's where the studio
looks slightly different the great ben
avery
flying down to uh make it seamless here
and for you to enjoy our you know our
lovely
curtain our studio is a curtain
and we want you to enjoy it and it's
simple it's like uh this is like uh
this is a table with a cloth on it it
looks like we uh it looks like we're a
bunch of veterans who sat up a table in
the nassau community
nassau coliseum in long island during
like
some type of trade show military history
you know show we have all kinds of
medals set up and we just want to talk
to you
um but i mean when ben showed me that
this morning i was like well it's here
like what do you do when it's here like
everything we've discussed i mean it's
just
here now
i don't know you want me to do uh uh
interviews with upcoming bands
i don't know but i mean this is
really truly 100 it's arrived
it's not on its way it's not coming
it's not a futuristic movie it's not an
article you read
it's not an idea it's not a joke it's
not a prank it is
100 in effect
it's here the dystopian nightmare
has a rot you don't know who's talking
to you if they're real
if they're dead when they were dead
you don't know if the people running for
president are alive are dead
they're being hidden everybody's got
coveted and then no one does
states are open and then they're not uh
i don't know
reality is a i don't know you just
you you key in we just had this hattie
bees nashville hot
chicken it's disgusting it's just
disgusting
what's wrong with you people
large swaths of this country are just
drunk near duels
who just like some local
garbage i mean the chicken
is like so hot you can't eat it
there's only one reason to have food
that hot
and that it's that you had to put so
much spice into it
because it's bad meat it's
bad meat just fry the chicken throw a
little spice in there
it shouldn't melt your face
off in the afternoon but a lot of people
like that here because they're drunk
and they're trying to become uh you know
the next
luke bryan trying to become a country
music star
how sad is that country music is sad
anyway even when it's great
so when you're failing at it it's very
it's like comedy
it's really like stand-up comedy when
you go walk into one of these bars in
nashville do you just see somebody with
a guitar be like
hey y'all i got molested as a girl or
whatever they sing about i don't know
but i am
i love country i like country i love it
but it is sad when you first start out
just like stand-up comedy you're
standing in a room
alone and you're revealing all these
things about yourself to uh
you know an audience of drunks who don't
care and then i guess you go eat hottie
bees
hot chicken which is now invading l.a
hot
chicken man white people love something
where if they eat it they feel ethnic
that's really what it is right they love
eating something spicy
white women named sarah with pit bulls
love eating spicy food
they do they love it so we're down here
in nashville and ben came down to put
the
studio together late last night as we're
falling asleep we just got word that the
president of the united states and his
lovely wife
melania trump who had a little whoopsie
she was on uh the phone and she was
talking about christmas decorations and
she goes who cares about this
who cares about this christmas [ __ ] but
i do it
i do it anyway the migrant kids who
cares
no one cares when obama does this to the
kids
poor melania trump you're hot you're
some slovenian model
you know you [ __ ] a billionaire he he
wifes you up
he locks you up in a golden tower he's
cheating on you you don't care
you might be cheating on him who knows
it's some type of arrangement
you're rich as [ __ ] things are going
well you're going out you're having fun
you know all of a sudden he goes listen
i'm gonna be the president of the united
states
and for a minute you think well that
might be a little fun and then as you
get into it you realize what an
absolute hell it is
i mean she is the most i don't want to
be disrespectful to say she's like a
mail-order bride but she's not
but let's be honest and say that if
donald trump
owned the plumbing company if he owned
the plumbing company
he's not married to melania trump
probably
right or many of his other wives it's
just what it is
i'm not i hope i'm not blowing anyone's
brains
with that information i i still hope you
believe in love
out there i still hope that you believe
in
a connection to soulmates eyes longingly
meeting in a cafe
i hope all of those things to you are
still real but let me not
let me not mince words here uh
there would be no way that melania and
donald would be together if donald
didn't have a little bit of a fortune
he has a sizeable fortune it makes him
appealing
a sizeable fortune and the lifestyle can
make someone appealing
and now she's in the white house and she
was brooding when she first got there
she wasn't really happy she didn't like
it
she was like a dump they thought it was
a dump you know they said that she had
to have the
obama's toilets removed she didn't like
any you know she thought it was like a
dump
because she wants to live you know in a
gold palace opulent
you know the white house is i guess kind
of plain for them you know
because they live like that because they
love the poor donald and melania trump
has
always had a deep affection for people
that worked in the coal mines in
pennsylvania
and ohio they love the rust belt that's
what they're about
you know forever and that's why they
they live in this opulent gold fortress
on fifth avenue and that's why they
didn't want to move to the white house
because they were like this is a dump
we don't want to move into this dump but
she finally got there
and um they had a very uh
i think they were kidding around when
they did christmas there i think that's
what she's talking about in this leaked
phone call
do we have that but right here we're
gonna play melania trump's leaked phone
call
i feel bad for these people i often feel
for billionaires i know that people say
i shouldn't
i often feel for the very rich
because you got to put yourself in their
position they're
very rich and all of this is just a
bother
like the idea that you're the guy
jeffrey that was at your house
now it's on the cover to paper that he's
running a
human trafficking ring it's like this is
annoying to me that's what being very
rich
feels like they're just annoyed all the
time there's just
little uh annoyances all the time oh
that woman just slain that used to come
to the house who used to have a couple
of uh drinks it was kind of funny she
was kind of funny
well she's you're not gonna believe this
she's running a human trafficking ring
for the mossad
and it's just their small annoyances
that you have you just get upset
like i get annoyed when uh you know the
wi-fi
at the airbnb doesn't work and i go this
is annoying
there's people get annoyed so i feel bad
for milani because poor melania trump's
now in the white house which is a dump
she's in the dumpy white it's not let's
be honest straight
it's not that nice it's not that nice
real estate has moved
on watch million dollar listing watch
selling sunset you can do
better than the white house you can do
better
than a [ __ ] old white plain house
that a bunch of school kids walk through
a bunch of fat middle americans taking
tours
every day ugh no thank you
so melania's already pretty disgusted
because she knows
she's in the private residence but when
she wakes up
every morning she knows before
that there were like gross people
on the other side of the house taking a
tour
and she's disgusted by that she's like
this is grotesque
she goes i didn't leave my country to
come here
to be with the american people i came
here to marry a billionaire and live
like a bit now i gotta do christmas
decorations
and worry about kids in the cages
so melania's like what the [ __ ] that
about
melania goes i know some women that went
in cages it was the best thing they ever
did
changed their life so here is a leaked
phone call i'm not a fan of leaks i
don't know where this came from her
senior advisor
or senior advice but this is just fun
and you can hear in melania's voice is
what i like about it
you can hear in melania's voice just the
frustration
with the whole thing like what is this
melania trump everybody
they say i'm complicit i'm the same like
him i support him i don't say enough i
don't do enough
no where i am i'm working like
a as my ass i know christmas stuff that
you know
who gives a [ __ ] about christmas stuff
and decoration but i need to do it right
yeah but imagine a hundred percent you
have no choice
and okay and then i do it and i say that
i'm working on christmas
uh planning for the christmas and they
said oh what about the children that
they were separated
give me a break
where they were saying anything when
obama did that i know
i cannot go i i was trying
to get the kid reunited with the mom i
didn't have a chance needs to go through
the process and through the law
but here's my thing hear what you just
said but instead of that
if if you just your messaging
you you were so loved you would not do
the story
we put it out they would not do the
story
until you would not believe it they
would not
do the story because no they are not
they would not do the story because they
they are
they are against us because they are
liberal media yeah if i go to fox they
will do the story
give me a break so give me a break put
the kids in the cage it's christmas time
give me a break with these [ __ ] kids
in a cage
we're having christmas i love her i like
her immediately don't you like her when
you hear that i like her
because you know what she's she's angry
she goes what they're saying i'm
complicit
what do you want me to do i'm [ __ ]
this guy for his money i'm taking his
money
melania trump's a feminist hero
she's stealing this guy's money while he
sleeps
now she's [ __ ] got coven they're
blaming her for the goddamn kids in the
cages
i feel for her she goes i did the
christmas decorations who gives a
[ __ ] about that who gives a [ __ ] but i
do it
and their christmas decorations were
weird people were saying on twitter it
looked like the uh
the upside down and stranger things they
were comparing it to the obamas because
obama's had like a warm
christmas thing and the trumps had like
i think it was like a cold winter
wonderland theme
i remember that yeah melania looked like
the white witch from narnia it was just
a strange
but i like i like a cold christmas
theme i feel for melania trump maybe i
vote for melania
how about that can i vote for just a
spouse
can i vote for jill biden the spouses
here have
got to be better than the men the women
have got to be better than the men
jill biden's got to be more on the ball
than him and from what i've just heard i
think melania is more qualified than
donald
to do this she's a she's a [ __ ]
slovenian gold digger nobody knows more
about america
than a woman like that who comes over
and marries donald trump
nobody understands this country better
than her by the way people want to [ __ ]
on her
she gets it she knows what motivates
people
what animates them
i mean the doomsday planes are up in the
air
ben told me and what now these doomsday
planes and they but they re they
activated them after trump got covered
and they didn't want anyone to freak out
they didn't want anybody upset about
this they just said
it was a coincidence it's a coincidence
it's happenstance
it's just one of those things that
happened we just put the doomsday planes
up in the air because we like to fly
we like to fly them around see what
happens to doomsday plane
and why do we call it the doomsday plane
no reason now these are the planes that
are what do they cost is something
absurd
so i'm like 220 million 220 million
dollars and the plane is supposed to be
able to withstand
what like nuclear radiation and yeah uh
in the event of a nuclear war disaster
or other large-scale conflict that
threatens key military and government
infrastructure
they're used by the airborne command
post oh good
and there's four of them there's four
doomsday planes
do we know how many of them have been
activated all of them
i'm not sure let me look that up we
don't know it's hard to know folks
i love sheath underwear it's amazing i
wear it in the pool it's fun it's like
an underwear but a bathing suit it's
great
it cradles your junk you t you tuck your
[ __ ] and balls into the front little
pouch
of it and it just cradles them it's very
nice it's fun it makes you look
it kind of stimulates you so you always
kind of have a little bit of a happy you
walk around
it looks nice it seems nice sheath
underwear they're big fans of the show
we really appreciate it they send us
free underwear
all the time it's great you don't ever
get sweaty or weird or anything like
that it's a nice underwear for people
and i think everybody should should buy
it
that's the way i feel do you agree with
that yeah all they have to do is use
promo code tim and save 20
are you telling me promo code tim will
save them 20 on sheath underwear 20
which is perfect as a bathing suit or in
the pool i mean it's just the most
versatile
piece of underwear you'll ever get
sheath underwear tim
is the promo code and they get 20 off
because that seems [ __ ]
wild it's crazy considering they're a
small business
they're a small business yes and if uh
it's a percent money back
on the first pair so you have nothing to
lose yeah if you don't like them you get
all your money back but you're gonna
love them
you're gonna love sheath underwear and
their small business is a great american
story
love them love uh sheath underwear is
worn by comedians and ufc fighters true
warriors on the front line
and if cowboy cerrone and ari shafir
wear sheaths
it's probably pretty decent would you
say tim well i don't love that
it's in the cop i don't love that
i don't love that copy i mean what are
we doing here i'm trying to sell you
underwear and you're telling me about
irish if you're in cowboy surround what
are we doing you're trying to are
we talking about couture or not why
don't i do ads for dior or chanel
[ __ ] it what am i doing here plugging
it's a good underwear that's what i'm
saying
it really is good i like it you don't
get that sweaty
it's like nice you know you know it's
nice
all right 20 off tim dylan just buy the
underwear to help the [ __ ] show
really enough folks
good underwear please it's for the show
just use promo code tim and save 2010 it
is a good product thank you
blue chew your dick well thank you it's
it's a blue chew
it has the same active ingredients as
all the viagra cialis and it's chewable
and there's no it's a good it's a great
dick pill and
there's no doctor visit no awkward uh
bumbling around the pharmacy they ship
it to your house and
or your mother's house in discrete
packaging you pick it right up you chew
it it works very quickly get that hit in
the bloodstream
the dick is hard you're ready to go to
work you [ __ ] good you might [ __ ] your
way into
uh some chick who's inheriting a lake
house or something i don't know but
so important to be on your game
bluetooth nobody's [ __ ] anymore
people are on so many ssris their dick
is
just like a a tiny uh thing of you know
whatever it doesn't even work because
everybody needs 12 pills so they don't
cry all the time now so
it's important to have the bluetooth
just chew it i chew a blue chew i wake
up i just look at my dick i say nice and
then i go right back to bed
it's important to do blue chew b-l-u
c-h-e-w what are the deals we have for
them benjamin i know we have so many
visit bluetooth.com and get your first
shipment free when you use our special
promo code
td just pay five dollars shipping pd
gets you five dollars of shipping you
visit bluetooth.com you use the td promo
code your first order is free
absolutely no risk and did you know uh
blue chew is made in the usa it's
prescribed online by licensed physicians
so
made in the usa
dick pills in the usa
the only jobs in america left are people
making your blue chew
so you don't have to go to the doctor or
wait in line it's even cheaper than a
pharmacy and they prepare and ship it
right to you in a discreet package no
awkwardness you don't have to go don't
eat anything
you don't have health insurance you
can't go to the doctor anyway even for
real things so [ __ ] that
get the blue chew
again that's bluetooth.com promo code td
dot com
promo code td i've got my opener on the
road with me dan carney i got up he got
upset with me uh
uh last night because i i was going in
on
sports journalists and i was suggesting
that people like jamelli hill
weren't geniuses really funny i was
it's sports it's it's what what are we
doing it's there are smart people that
are athletes
let's get this out of the way for all of
you that are angry at me and go oh tim
you're fat and you're not an athlete and
that's why you're gonna do blah
no no i am an athlete i'll beat you in a
swim race
i was a great athlete third fastest
butterflyer on long island at seven
years old that counts
that kid doesn't matter i'm fat now it
counts then i was winning then
you've never won but a journalist who
covers
basketball is not an intelligent human
being
enough they're not bright
it's what it is most journalists who
cover politics aren't bright
there's like five of them that i respect
but let's stop but
but here's the problem this little guy
who i love he's great
but he you know he had like a basketball
podcast you know what they do is they
get
the kit you can't tell you can't tell
anyone under 30 right now that they're
not the greatest thing to
have existed on earth because they think
it's abuse
they stare at you like you're abusing
them if you tell them that they are not
the you know the reincarnation of jesus
christ on the planet
so when when he goes so he everybody
likes things they could talk with
authority about
sure you know what i mean people like
the things they could speak with
authority about
uh so when i was uh denigrating
people to talk about sports
professionally for money
he got a little mana because he's got
you know he had a basketball
podcast with his very attractive friend
i used to tune in every now and then
because
the friend is like insanely attractive
and then you know of course there's the
one that i
usually spend time with but they're just
not
i mean sports are important we need them
as a country they're good i'm all for
that competition blah blah blah i'm with
it all
and there's some very smart people that
are coaches and i get that
but when you talk about the people that
are are
sports journalists i mean
i don't know how many real geniuses you
have in that crew
am i is that controversial statement i
don't think so are people getting angry
at me
i like bob costas he's kind of he's
pretty smart
yeah brian gumbel i mean i'm not saying
there aren't there aren't smart people
out there
yeah bill bill simmons yeah there's a
lot of smart bit but
but by and large on the whole let's
cut it out what are they analyzing balls
going in a hole
that's what they're doing no there's
more to it than that not really
not really it isn't
i am i wrong here they're analyzing a
game
that can be played by children it's not
but it can be understood by a child
that's why children
play sport children don't play war and
peace
they don't play geopolitics
because they don't understand it but
they can understand sports
because it's pretty simple there is a
hoop the ball will now go
in the hoop
is that not what's being analyzed am i
wrong here
is there something deeper than that i
know with the sjw [ __ ]
and the politics everybody wants to you
know pretend but let's be very honest
here
i mean you love golf are you gonna get
mad at me if i say golf is
simple no if i'm writing about it as a
journalist is it relatively simple no
you're whacking a little ball in the
woods
tiger woods dad at four years old said
you're gonna be great and he got great
i turner did the same thing to his
ex-wife tina
said you're gonna be great and she got
great
i'm not talking about methods it doesn't
matter i turner didn't say to tina go
out to honey and figure it out on your
own time
he said let's get it moving and what
happened legend
what happened to tiger woods legend but
how complex is this this isn't the cold
war
it's golf it's [ __ ] basketball
cut it out no tim it's you don't
like sports you're gay and gay people
don't appreciate sport
i love that sports the drama the
competition i get it
just don't come around and tell me
people that recap
reality shows are also not bright
am i hurting anyone's feelings when i
say that
people whose main job is to do a recap
of a reality show these are not terribly
intelligent human beings
they're crafty and savvy maybe there's
many of them
all over the place on social media but
the first words
i think of are not intelligence
when somebody's breaking down a scene
that happened on love island or
whatever horror is being delivered to us
there's not a lot of smart people on
this planet
there's not there's a very small there's
a very small group
it is a curse that i'm one of i don't
want to be one of them
i'd rather not be one of them i'd rather
not be one of the smart people
i don't want that i'd rather have a huge
dick and a six-pack and not know
anything but i
am an oracle of wisdom oh no
i didn't know that was gonna happen but
it happened
people get mad at me because uh because
you know they don't they don't think
that i respect their uh basketball
podcast enough
stavey baby has a basketball podcast
divers i'm sure it's fine mustavi
wouldn't tell you this is a genius level
right because we're talking about sports
which is not complex
it's not that complicated people make it
to be very complex it's not that
complicated
by the way you have a lot of money you
buy the good players some of them get
hurt you got to buy
other ones
ah am i i'm going to get so much hate
for this but i don't i don't i don't
understand it it it's relatively
weak i get it i i love athlete
like i like i i'm i'm i'm really
impressed
by somebody that gets up every day
and puts work into their their ability
to do something
physically i think that is great i'm a
big proponent of that
um but again
are they the brightest people
no no in fact
being dumb is a great asset if you're an
athlete
it is it's so so important mentally yeah
to be
kind of dumb if you're an athlete
if you think you're gonna think your way
out of winning i'm telling you
if you're too intelligent it's a curse
you gotta be into the physicality the
body
the the moving around the the just
focus tunnel vision every day
ball hole
you can't be you with your mind it going
in 10 different directions
you can't be a deeply contemplative
person
i think it helps to be
a little dull little dense
we don't want and that's where you see
athletes they're gorgeous
and they're beautiful we love them we
need them but you don't they're not
you know they're not exactly the
smartest people
it's true i'm telling you the truth
you don't want the truth you go
somewhere else just don't get mad at me
i felt bad this little guy got mad
he talks when you know he'll make a
point with sports he gets in a
tone and he's like well what you have to
understand
shut up what are you saying are you on
the team
are you on the team are you making money
from the team
then what are we doing here what i have
to understand
what do i have to understand about the
golden state warriors what do i really
have to understand
what's essential that i understand okay
not much but you can't you can't talk to
somebody who's young
and tell them that i mean it's also like
i've done this rant before i'm not gonna
do it again but
men treat sports like women treat
fashion they all like it they all think
that there's some job in it for them and
in many cases there's not okay
you're not gonna be dave portnoy and
you're not gonna be [ __ ] tory burch
it's just what it is
every [ __ ] girls running around
college going i love fashion i want to
work in fashion
and a lot of guys like i want to be a
sports agent because they like sports
everybody likes sport
it's like majoring in tits
you like [ __ ] too i mean i don't but
it's pretty popular
i mean that's what people like i like
fashion what do you mean you like being
hot right no
fat chick ever says that no grotesque
monster goes i like [ __ ] on i
love [ __ ] they don't love
fashion hot chicks like fashion because
they like
looking hot it's not a job i mean it is
a job
melania but the reality is so
people just lose their minds when you
when you tell them
i mean this guy i think he majored in
like exercise science or something
majored in the elliptical
i mean the guy i mean this is a major
now sports medicine
and what toy was sports medicine
what is that jerking off an ex-major
league baseball player
is that what we're doing he majored in
that something
you know i get here's what the hell is
that major here's your knee cream what
are we doing
but that's what he majored in he majored
in uh fitness and i don't know the
philosophy of the treadmill
weight training you know i don't get it
they studied what proust had to say
about the ketogenic diet
i don't know i'm just saying it's
not a major and you'd not intelligent
i get it you're all you're good looking
i appreciate that and i respect
that and you all have discipline but
don't come at me
and get mad at me
for just saying a little bit of truth
audiences in nashville have been fine
they've been good we sold out six shows
they have not been as amazing as texas
i've been really getting into texas
a lot uh we're really thinking about
we're thinking about maybe moving los
angeles we talked about this earlier
today we're thinking about getting out
of california
and and it it's it it part of it is
the economic collapse the fires
the homelessness the civil unrest
the racial tension the policing
uh the lack of freedom the dirt
the diseases that are coming back the
high cost of living
the high property tax burden the high
income tax burden
the mismanagement of the state uh the
political
uh issues um the earthquakes
earthquakes the tectonic issues
that's just to name a few negatives
the death of hollywood how embarrassing
it is to even be in this business
the idea that everything is independent
now and you don't have to be in los
angeles to get any opportunities
and nobody's giving you any
opportunities you give them to yourself
and the opportunities you get can get
taken right away and we're thinking
we're thinking about moving and i got to
be honest with you i'm for no other
reason
and me and ben literally just threw a
[ __ ] we looked at
america and we threw a [ __ ] pin
at the country and and and we didn't
even know where it was going to go
we're thinking about maybe austin texas
and it's just and we threw a pin and it
was the room was dark
and the map was dark and we just threw a
pin
and i said what is that and it was
austin texas and it's
so and again i don't know if we'll know
anyone there
i don't know if anyone we know lives
there probably not
will probably be alone will probably be
the biggest podcast in austin texas
if we move there i'm not saying we will
but i imagine if we do we'll be number
one
pretty quickly but maybe we'll go there
i don't know i spoke to a realtor i
called a realtor but you know me and do
a little fake business i don't know if
it becomes real business but i i i'm a
little sick of the idea
when you sit in la and you sit in these
restaurants
and you watch how silly this town is
how sad it is
uh in la you have two extremes of people
you have 16 year olds who've just
arrived
the tick tock kids who are running
around the paparazzi are chasing them
they they've got to see you know they've
got it's a quick burn their careers but
they're getting
money stuff down their throat uh they're
having a ball
um and then on the other side you have
people that won't
let fame go they won't let it go
they just you know they're holding on to
it for dear life
that both of those things are very
interesting to watch
you're between both of them in la you
have people that are
relevant for no reason immediately
uh who are like just in a daze they're
in a haze
these kids don't even know what's
happening they're just being followed
around
by paparazzi they're making all this
money some of them are savvier than
others but they're
they're just like wow what the [ __ ] and
then on the other end you have people
that are
just at the end you know
they're they've they've done it they've
done what they came to do
and many of them don't know that yet no
one's informed them no one's pulled them
aside and said
you've done this you did it it's time to
graduate
here's your diploma now walk out you
should have did this
years ago walk out with the class now
you can't keep coming back into the
school we know you like the pep rallies
we know you like the pep rallies we know
you like homecoming
we know you enjoy it we know it's fun
and you feel
just like you felt the first time you
did it but i'm here to tell you this
everybody's creeped they're creeped out
you know and i'm telling you it's like
grizzabella if you've seen
cats it's a gay podcast i [ __ ] on sports
i'm talking about cats but
isabella in in in the play cats
is like an old uh cat and she's like she
sings memories
and she's like this ratty cat that walks
out
and that's what you have in hollywood
you got a bunch of ratty cats
walking around they don't know it's time
to go
die and cats go die alone sometimes you
gotta go die alone
whitney was making me laugh whitney
cummings was like obsessed with helping
animals
and uh which is what i like about her if
she helped people it would be grotesque
but i liked it she loves animals
and uh she kept picking up a cat on her
way back to the comedy store taking it
to the animal hospital and they kept
going
the cat's just trying to die like cats
go alone to die
so like literally this cat is trying to
die and the whitney's like putting it on
her instagram like
saved it again and the cat's like let me
die
so that's what la is there's a lot of
people there that you just got
let them walk out but i look and i go
what's my place here you know what's my
place what am i going to do am i really
am i going to walk around jake paul's
compound you know with an ar-15 and
protect him am i going to
what am i going to do what what is my
purpose here what is my point
i i sit in a boa steakhouse and i i
stare at these these uh kids and they're
walking around you know with face
tattoos
and they roll on on drugs i've barely
even heard of
you know uh you know they're just
they're just
dancing you know they're dancing in
front of their cream spinach and they're
making more money
than i could even ever imagine you know
and i'm just sitting there like where do
i fit into all of this
what am i going to be in the merch is
that what i'm gonna do is that why i
came to la to sell
t-shirts i just want to sell merch
this is my new shirt new drop some new
drops coming
new merch drops coming we're dropping it
it's getting dropped it's merch things
you can wear
things you can wear you wear them i sell
them you buy them i'm an
artist is that what we're here to do
folks you want sneakers now we are going
to do merge and don't
don't when i do that don't come back
with this and tell me i've done the
wrong thing
i'm not letting it become my whole
identity that's the point that doesn't
mean i'm not going to do it i've done it
in the past
but i mean the excitement people have
over merged
get it it's getting dropped is that
we're supposed to i mean the now kids
make
a trillion dollars every time they do a
drop it says full send
they've got make billions of dollars
those kids
i like those kids i i because they
embrace the darkness of the world in a
different way
they go to college campuses and tell
everybody to just [ __ ] the corona out of
each other and
jump headfirst into a pool and do all
the drugs and you know
light your parents car on fire i respect
that
you know they do fun pranks like i don't
know they drink beer in front of cops
and
get in fights they go to jail they try
to recreate 911
all of that stuff i think is good
it's interesting it's better than a lot
of the [ __ ] my friends are doing
let them do it good for them but the mur
i mean the merch these p
they just go wild with the merch
everybody what
young kid they just want that full send
and god love them
send me a full sense sweatshirt and i'll
wear it but is that what we're supposed
to do are we supposed to hang out in la
and just meet
and talk about merch until we both blow
our brains out
is that what i'm gonna do to design a
hoodie
my other merch is a joke it's fun you
should wear it it's cool but it's a joke
we got a guy to do a sketch it's a it's
a bit
and it's funny i'm going to sit down now
and
like i'm a design like i'm a fashion
designer and you look at me you go i
want
merch from ham what is that
comedians are now that
can you imagine some guy talking to
kenneth and be like now you're at you're
also a stylist
how did that come about yeah i've got a
new line of merch
about my time as a tent preacher sam
kinnison's doing a new
ship station a lot of people right now
are looking at e-commerce online
business very smart go get this [ __ ] all
over your house and sell it online
it is smart well how do you ship it how
do you keep track of your big orders
your small orders
you don't want to do all the back office
work you need to be creative keep making
whatever
garbage you're selling to people online
you need ship station shipstation
is a product that can basically take
alleviate the burden of you
having to do all the back office work
shipstation is very easy it helps you
ship
all kinds of things whether your
shipping needs are very large or very
small
shipstation will let you tailor the
program to fit your specific needs as a
small
or growing business shipstation is
amazing it takes
all of the hassle out of doing an online
e-commerce business it is amazing
it utilizes all the major shipping
companies finds you the best rates it
allows you to scale up or down depending
on the volume that you're doing
ship station is very important you can
get three months of it free and you know
when you start a business it's very hard
to turn a profit immediately imagine
if you could get three months of this
amazing 60 days 60 days
you of course you want three months you
greedy pig
you're getting two months two [ __ ]
months you want three
no you don't get three it's still
america 60 days of this amazing product
free
all they have to do is go to ship
station and use promo code what
tim dillon promo code tim dillon a trip
station you get 60 days of this product
free the first
two months half the quarter on the arm
you can organize
you can make sure that you know that
your products are being shipped
efficiently to the people buying them
you can make sure that there is no
backlog
you're not doing meetings and calls
you're not running around
it is easily accessible quick
digital everything you want it to be
it's so easy to use
yeah you just have to click on the mic i
enjoy it so much i don't even have a
business i just ship
blank boxes to people and i go did you
get that and they go yeah what the hell
is in it and i go nothing you know
what's in it
peace of mind because i know that ship
station's doing a job
just click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in template
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in tim dillon and
all of it starts you're going to be
warren buffett
ridge wallet
ridge wallet is the product we've been
advertising on this show maybe the
longest it is a titanium carbon fiber
wallet it comes in
many different colors and flavors and
samples it is metallic it is easy to use
you slide it in your front pocket
it is easy you keep a slight amount of
cash a little cash a card
your lawyer's number it makes you pare
down all the
unnecessary [ __ ] the wads of garbage you
keep in your other wallet
ridge wallet is great it is discreet
people barely know you have it it is
easy to sanitize
put it between both of your hands rub it
together with some sanitizer and then
bam you're good to go it's not an
old leather wallet with business cards
of people that never did business with
you an old cash a kingdom that came out
of a stripper's [ __ ]
it is a ridge wallet it is new it is new
wave you're going to be into it
futuristic it looks cool it'll get you
laid
somebody at the bar man or woman will
look at you and go i want to [ __ ] you
because you've got that ridge wallet
you'll say thank you
that's the way it works ridge wallet is
amazing everybody loves it
all the podcasters love it it's so easy
it's so great
they've got a lot of great products the
wallet is amazing uh it is ridge wallet
what are we doing there how do we how
are we giving them free shipping
worldwide shipping and returns if you
don't like it but you know you're gonna
love it yeah and on top of that you get
ten percent off ten percent off how
about that and what do we what is the
code here
ridge.com and use code tim ridge.com
tim and use code tim ridge.com tim and
use code tim and i'll tell you what
folks
we are partying
i mean i don't know i just look around
at la and i go where do i fit
where do i fit 97 of people that do
comedy are mentally ill
three percent of us are mentally ill and
funny
it's the only difference
you got two clubs in l.a you got the
improv and the comedy store and the ice
house
okay and flappers
and i love the the ice house and i love
the improv and i love the store but i
don't know when things are open i don't
know when garcetti is going to open that
up
they were going to do shows in the
parking lot of the comedy store and they
[ __ ] they already said no
right somebody ratted them out some rat
you know the saddle ranch which is next
to the comments
it's a you want to talk about a horrific
restaurant
i mean beyond like it's like chicken
fingers
it's the most popular restaurant in l.a
right now
they've set up tables and chairs in the
parking lot
and the tick tock kids go in there and
they throw chicken fingers at each other
what is why is the earthquake not here
i mean what is going on how do you take
this place seriously
how does one grow old here with any
dignity
explain that to me show me how
i get it why rupaul went and started
fracking
okay i'm gonna start fracking if i make
a little more money on this patreon i'm
gonna go to
you know rupaul's got [ __ ] gas lines
in kazakhstan
and i get it what are you gonna [ __ ]
do sit at the saddle ranch
and eat coleslaw while 15 year olds
finger [ __ ] each other
in front of the paparazzi you got to
move into other things
christ almighty i used to like la when i
first met benjamin
we used to sit in benjamin's uh
garage and watch info wars and you know
the news
and we'd have a lot of fun and we did
the sketches and they were fun and we'd
go and do
spots and we'd go to the house of pies
and eat pies which were
good but not great but ben really loved
them but
did i get you the brimeyer farms pie i
didn't get it for you
uh the one me you and ray did on the in
long island
is that the one you're talking about
where we got the pie and the cider
no the brime here is a raspberry cream
from from the the east
end by the hamptons we didn't get it
that time but that's the pie
but the point is you know at a certain
point you gotta just know when to hold
them know when to fold them i guess
what's coming good here show me what's
good
why am i staying why am i staying here
the business i'm in has melted
it's it is goo on the ground
now the idea of having a tv show
is embarrassing it would have been bat
you're embarrassed now if you have a tv
show
oh are you the guy from that show no
are you the guy from that show on true
tv where they talk about whose dog house
is better
no yes you are that's the guy from true
tv
are you the guy that hosts the hot dog
challenge no i'm not
please just drive me home i saw your
show it's really
funny it's an embarrassment already
enough is enough we reno 9-1-1 arguably
one of the funniest shows
of the last decade ends up coming back
on quibby
which is like this app that's a [ __ ]
complete
mess where you're supposed to download
it and watch high
quality stuff shows in seven minute
increments
it's like a joke it's called quibby
these always have dumb names
nbc did something called cso now they're
doing peacock
and is everybody lining up to watch
peacock
what's your favorite show i like the
show on peacock
what are you saying sounds like a gay
bar
i want to go to peacock
i'm watching my shows on come stream
i mean i just think it's it's kind of a
joke now the show is what we're doing
the studio is
is what we make it and what we do the
videos are what we decide they are
the guests or who we book the live show
is what the live show is i mean
there's no other components here and
there's there's something a little
frustrating about that when you hit a
wall and you go wait a minute what's
the goal is to just try to keep being
funny and keep introducing new elements
to this show to make it better
and and and and that is um that's
interesting and it's challenging but
i'll tell you this right now
i i have a very bleak view of the
future of of the mainstream of
this business and my place in it
specifically
and when you when you when you get rid
of that the reasons to live in la are
not that many
it's not a beach ain't that nice it's
nice it's not bad
hermosa beach is beautiful malibu's okay
but the amount of money you spend there
and the hassle of living there versus
other places to live
like austin texas maybe
we don't know
completely random selection
is a very weird random selection to
choose there but
i don't know what the hub of comedy's
gonna be i don't think it's gonna be in
la and you know what i went back to new
york and i love new york and i'm you
know a new yorker and blah blah blah i'm
not too impressed with new york at the
moment i just
i'm not too bro i think new york's got a
lot of pain ahead of it
and god bless the people that still live
i've never defined my life by uh
geography
some people i'm in new york shut up what
are you
what are you freak i'm a new york
shut up what'd you do think new york
gives a [ __ ] about you
i've never defined my life by a zip code
i like to get out there
i don't really give a [ __ ] where i live
as long as we can work
and make funny [ __ ] um
but yeah i'm not going back to new york
i'll tell you that much
not with de blasio not with that [ __ ]
nightmare
and all these people in new york are
like it's gonna go back to being gritty
and all the orders to come back yeah but
there's none
you see none of you are talented okay
this is like cbg cbgb but everybody
sucks
there's no david byrne in the talking
heads you can't play the guitar
so you're just getting stabbed and then
there's no upside it's all bad
i got beat up on the way to the club now
i get to walk in and hear this hack
it was horrible it sucks
there's some great comics in new york
but let's be honest comedy right now is
just full of people that
for the most part should be locked in a
home
they should not be there should be
contact tracing for comedians where'd
you go
who'd you see who would you talk to
not all of them but a fair amount i'm
not too impressed with new york
i don't know the once great city and i'm
sure it'll be great again i don't know
that's 35 years old i don't have the
time to wait around through another
few cycles of uh you know people uh
of bloodletting i don't need to wait
around through the bloodletting ben's
trying to start a family
i'm trying to start a harem of lacrosse
players
i don't need to be sitting there for
five years
waiting for like bill de blasio or
whoever he's gonna maybe get ousted in
months maybe not 12 months whenever that
election is
we're a month away from the presidential
election in america
the president is quarantining for two
weeks
all souls day halloween the doomsday
planes are in the air
we've got people being recreated dead
parkland kids
are being recreated and turned into
[ __ ]
voting psas we are
there so you got to decide where you
want to be
you got to decide what physical location
you want to be when there
gets worse because we're already there i
just don't know where there goes
and it could be somewhere not good you
might want a little property you might
want a little space
if you can swing it you can't swing it
that's okay
too but something's coming
something's ready here and it's not good
and many of us that have paid attention
kind of understood this was happening
it's been happening for decades and
decades this is not new
if you've read a book or two that
weren't recommended to you
that you stumbled upon and found and you
understood the deep trouble that we've
been in for a while
and and the the propensity for that
trouble to get even worse
then this isn't a shock how quickly it's
all happening is a little shocking
it's a little stunning i was my mouth
was wide today when i saw that
kid get recreated i was i was kind of
shocked at that
so me and ben might go back to texas
ben's a texas boy
he grew up he grew up in the in the
texas hills
just walking around looking for
the devil
we got some live news tim what is it
trump is on his way to the hospital
really he's yeah he's departing the
white house by helicopter late friday
uh the official said the visit was
precautionary and that trump would work
from the hospital's
hospital's presidential suite uh early
friday the white house said trump
remains fatigued
and had been injected with an
experimental anti-body cocktail but he
is going to be at a military hospital
for those
this weekend very bad news
this is very very bad news and um
obviously nobody wants well i don't want
i'm not going to say nobody because i'm
i'm sure that that's not a factual thing
um
nobody wants trump to be uh impaired
drastically by this number one if you're
a thinking person you realize
um how vulnerable that makes the country
even though you know the pentagon will
step in
um you want an election to happen here
you don't want uh
somebody who's drastically impaired uh
this is a
very very trying time uh it is truly um
we're on the the brink here we're on the
verge we're in the edges
as much as we joke around as much as we
have fun on the show it's what our job
is
uh we are on the brink of some some
challenges that are
that could prove insurmountable in the
short term and i
i i think that people don't quite
understand that you know we we
we are heading towards a place there's
never been less trust
i mean if you go back to civil war and
stuff fine but just for the for the
purposes of the point i'm gonna make
there's never been less trust
in this country than what i see now uh
people are quick to violence
uh nobody trusts any of the major
institutions the media the government
um we have a a pandemic
we have an economic collapse we have uh
the president of the united states in
the hospital we have an election that's
already very contentious
unraveling uh and unfolding uh where
we're gonna have some answer in a
month's time
um it's i mean
one of my favorite quotes hell is empty
and all the devils
are here william shakespeare i mean
truly this makes 2009 look like a cake
walk in the park 2009 we just had a
recession we had a cool black dude
running the show
and everybody was like we'll figure it
out
but as as far as this goes we are right
now
we got dead people coming back to do
commercials
here how's that great bill hicks joke
about that
that yule brenner when he died it was an
anti-smoking psa and bill hicks was like
yo brenner's like the commercial was i'm
joel brenner and i'm dead now
bill hicks was like what's he selling
a great joke um
trump headed to the hospital
precautionary visit with covet
he's on a cocktail of regeneran it's an
experimental answer he's getting the
best he's getting the best
how i mean this could mean war with
china this could just be you know a war
with china
i mean truly how he has a fever he's
very he's lethargic
they said this is just all precautionary
is he 75
i think trump's 74 let me see i mean
this is who it's gonna get
this is how it's who it gets 74.
yeah i mean 74 is not the age you want
to be if you get corona overweight too
he's overweight yeah you know bad diet
doesn't eat the best foods
i mean you want to talk about
shakespearean if he died of coronavirus
right it's a little shakespearean yeah
a little crazy if he died of that
um if his condition worsened
that would be
i mean this is this is the wildest
period in american history i think other
than
really world war ii or the civil war i
mean i just can't think of anything
where there's just been a succession of
events that have happened one after
another
like this you know
it it highlights even how silly la is
what a silly unserious place it is
when this stuff starts to happen
and you start to realize now that you
know we're in unchartered waters here i
mean boris johnson went to the hospital
with this
yeah and he came out okay but it was
tough it was tough
yeah and he was much younger than trump
probably both in
not great shape but
a precautionary visit yeah boris was 56.
here's the thing man he would not be
going to the hospital if there was
nothing going on
that's how i'm kind of yeah i they'd
have
they'd have doctors come in there they
have doctors
there would come in right so he's going
to the hospital
and it's not
it's not good i mean
uh the power has not been transferred to
the vice president yet
but uh this is all live on drudge i'm
here right now yeah
yeah huh wow
mike pence is healthy right
we're sitting in an airbnb in nashville
you know
it's like we're sitting in an airbnb in
nashville
the president of the united states has
just gone to the hospital coronavirus
the 74 year old overweight president
of the united states who happens to be
donald trump
today i woke up and i watched a child
who was killed in a parkland school
shooting
get reanimated to come back and deliver
an anti-gun
psa okay i then scrolled down on my
phone to be informed that
trusted institutions was uh at record
lows
and people were already starting to see
irregularities with the voting in the
election
which has been taking place absentee
for i believe a few weeks
then i looked at the earthquakes that
are happening
right where i live out in the desert in
california that could suggest a larger
and bigger earthquake
okay then i ate some
truly mediocre hot chicken out of a box
that my opener waited 35 minutes to get
all the while on the line probably
cursing me because i didn't understand
the importance of his basketball podcast
okay now we sit down
try to do a nice little episode for
everybody
talk about the things that are happening
defend the honor of the great
grifter and gold digger melania trump
yes yes who's uh i don't know if she's
in the hospital you think she's
accompanying donald to the hospital
probably she's she has mild symptoms so
she's supposedly fine
she'll she'll be fine those eastern
europeans i mean come on they come to
the country in a crate
you think you can you can get them
we're on the verge of a civil war
conflict with china
we're ready to trade war with them cold
war hot war
a a a country of endless griffs
the month of october the month of
october
want to make a hack pumpkin spice latte
joke here but you just can't
because we're on the verge of
you could wake up tomorrow and the
president could not be here anymore and
it'd be pandemonium oh yeah
it could happen during one of my shows
tonight we could get word
god forbid we don't want this that the
president is in a coma or passed out or
dead or anything
during one of my comedy shows and
i mean
what a time to be performing
stand-up comedy somebody could yell out
a heckle during my set like trump's dead
now or something
and i guess i would just have to say all
right well in light of this news i don't
think it's appropriate to continue the
show
right that makes sense yeah that's what
i would say
i think that's what i would say if
something like that were to happen and i
i don't usually do stuff like that but i
would say kind of like in light of
the recent developments i would say
tragic i'm in nashville
i'd say a lot of the recent tragic
developments uh it is inappropriate now
for me to continue my show
but we do have a merch table outside
with a hoodie
that i've spent months designing for you
so if you want to get in on this
merch but man
it's [ __ ] wild now
i don't know where this goes this is the
willy wonka boat ride that we're on here
you know
can you get that up can we play that a
little bit or exactly the willy wonka
boat ride yeah
maybe see if we can get that up
they get on the boat with wonka i can
see he's mentally unstable
if that song's not copyrighted i think
we should be able to
it's probably all copyrighted yeah it's
copyrighted all right
well youtube will take all our money
youtube will say no more money
wow
well we hope the president has a speedy
recovery
we hope there is an election that it is
fair
that people are happy with the result
and no one's ever going to be happy with
anything but
the people are confident that it was a
free election
and that we still have a democracy
i really hope that you know yeah
but don't we will be a dictatorship with
merch
like we will still have merch don't
worry about it
the military junta will be firmly in
place
i will all be selling each other [ __ ]
hoodies
with funny wacky faces on them
i don't know what to tell you
i'll use a sports analogy it feels like
it's time for a hail mary
how about that is that fun for everyone
a little sports analogy right now
we're in end times it's an odd place to
broadcast
from yeah it's an odd place to plug
dates which i'm about to do right now
but
during end times where are you getting
your chuckles
because right after this we've got
shows in salt lake city utah
we've got shows in tampa we have shows
in palm beach florida we have shows in
chicago
we have shows in oklahoma we have shows
in denver
and we have shows in kansas city and
then we are wrapping up this leg of the
tour and then we're going to chill for a
few months
in the winter keep doing the podcast get
some of our energy back
regenerate you know and phoenix too
and phoenix which is not selling well so
if you're out there in phoenix please
buy tickets
um phoenix is selling okay everything
else is really sold out every market
really except phoenix
i mean and we've added shows so there's
tickets in every market but there we've
added shows
uh phoenix could do a little better
speaking of phoenix we hope donald j
trump rises
like a phoenix
you think melania's at his bedside right
now with a lawyer and the will
donald you made promises to me
manny pro donald i have to put up
christmas decorations who gives a [ __ ]
about them wow
i mean by the time this is out he might
be
i don't know i mean we're hoping that
that does not happen but i mean
it i've never really we've never
seen some the wheels come off something
so quickly
i i mean i don't i can't even imagine i
can't
i can't even begin to tell you uh how
how quick the wheels have come off this
society
truly um
but
you know
get that merch
good night